et salut à tous aujourd'hui je vous
emmène avec moi on va aller ajouté plein
de choses on va parler de bonne comment
améliorer ses vidéos des petites choses
très simples qu'on peut faire et qu'il
faudrait faire même tous les jours ou
assez régulièrement mais tout ça après
l'intro et un café
[Musique]
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
faire de la vidéo en fait c'est un petit
peu comme un sport c'est calciné stats
qui en a parlé pas tout à fait dans le
même sens que ce que je dis là mais
c'est un sport dans le sens où si on
s'entraîne pas un minimum si on fait pas
régulièrement un effort temps on risque
de perdre ses compétences et on va pas
augmenter en compétences c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut faire très
régulièrement il faut sortir shooter
c'est pour ça que je vous amène avec moi
aujourd'hui je viens rien ajouté de
particulier je me balade juste et
j'essaie de trouver des choses qui sont
plutôt sympas à prendre comme bats pour
le café là c'était c'est un joli café en
plus il est très bon ce qu'a fait donc
j'en ai profité pour m'entraîner pour
essayer des choses prendre le temps d'en
gentiment aux jambes parce que si vous
voulez faire un marathon et que vous
n'êtes absolument pas entraîner vous
n'allez pas y arriver sa certitude
d'être même vous blesser et l'idée c'est
d'en faire un petit peu tous les jours
pour que le jour où on a quand même un
gros événement ajouter un ou deux trucs
ajoutant soit prêt donc c'est à
considérer exactement comme un sport ça
nécessite de l'entraînement
alors truc à prendre en compte aussi
c'est que souvent on se dit oui mais bon
en fait j'ai rien a ajouté j'ai rien à
filmer deux particulièrement intéressant
je suis dans un endroit où il ya pas
grand chose d'extraordinaire ben
justement en fait ça c'est une bonne
contrainte c'est un truc qui est plutôt
sympa moi je viens souvent au même
endroit essayé de filmer les choses de
manière différente essayer de trouver
des petits détails que j'avais pas vu
avant d'essayer justement vu que c'est
un endroit que je connais je connais les
endroits qui sont un petit peu sympa et
essayer une nouvelle technique que j'ai
vu dans une vidéo et même essayer d'être
juste un peu plus créatifs et de me dire
bah tiens voyons comment ça pourrait
rendre si j'y vais à telle heure
voyons si j'essaye avec tel objectif
voir si c'est si c'est différent
donc en fait la contrainte de rien
autour de chez moi que je peux filmer
qui soit sympa c'est justement à un truc
pour se booster la créativité en fait ça
nous obliger à être créatif et quand on
va se retrouver devant un paysage de ouf
ou quelque chose qui a plutôt
extraordinaire qui sort de l'ordinaire
on va arriver beaucoup plus facilement
il ya une espèce de frelons qui ne
tourne autour on va arriver beaucoup
plus facilement à utiliser toutes les
techniques de créativité en plus s'il ya
quelque chose de spécial vraiment un
film
alors l'autre truc qui est la super
positif dans le fait de sortir de chez
soi un peu comme ça sans raison et
d'aller shooter des choses un petit peu
random c'est que ça rassure tout
simplement je donne un exemple tout bête
dans trois jours jeu pour faire un
fromage sur un clip qui est
assez conséquente on a sur 2 jours vers
pas mal de montage et tout ça il ya
plein d'éléments de technique
sur lesquels je me sens bien mais mais
bon il ya quand même beaucoup de choses
à penser alors le simple fait de sortir
et puis ne serait-ce que de tester un
petit peu les choses que j'ai prévu par
rapport à ce clip justement et de les
tester en conditions comme ça il ya
toujours des corbeaux en fait quand je
filme c'est un truc de malade
donc le fait que le fait de les tester
des regrets de corbeaux peu fait
de les tester en conditions réelles bas
ça va me rassurer aussi me dire bon ben
voila j'ai testé un petit peu avant ce
que je voulais faire ça passe bien ça ça
va le faire ça va le faire donc déjà
voilà ça vous entraîne ça vous rassure
aussi comme s'il ya des des plans
importants
et puis il ya encore une dernière chose
mais ça on va parler juste après le
petit birol qui va suivre
[Musique]
et enfin la dernière raison pour
laquelle c'est toujours intéressant de
sortir et d'aller signer en bas de chez
soi des choses qu'on connaît des choses
qui ont a priori pas grand intérêt c'est
que ça va vous permettre de maîtriser
mieux aussi votre matériel s'apprend
vachement de temps de maîtriser son
matériel de connaître tous les
raccourcis des boutons les possibilités
ne serait-ce que voilà quand on
travaille sur les filtres et n'est plus
on s'en sert plus on sait quand il faut
pas s'en servir aussi
voilà ça va être quand utiliser le slow
mots comment régler au mieux votre seul
au mot par exemple ça peut être tout un
tas de choses mais utiliser le matériel
ça vous permet de le connaître et ça sur
un tournage après derrière pour un
client ou un tournage important c'est
quelque chose d'indispensable qui on va
vous faire gagner du temps et va vous
éviter de paniquer aussi parce qu'on a
déjà suffisamment de stress en tournage
si en plus on se rappelle plus comment
on obtient de tels effets ou comme on
utilise telle fonctionnalité d'autres
appareils
c'est beaucoup plus anxiogène que si on
n'en maîtrisent toutes les
fonctionnalités et ça fait
accessoirement aussi beaucoup plus pro
[Musique]
et voilà les amis c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aura donné envie de sortir votre
caméra et d'aller shooter devant cheyrou
des choses que vous avez déjà vu des
choses que vous connaissez mais que vous
avez envie de voir sur un angle nouveau
caméra smartphones gopro ce que vous
voulez hein ça marche avec tous si ça
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à mettre le
traditionnel pouce en l'air en dessous
de cette vidéo laisser des commentaires
dans les mois votre avis puis
abonnez-vous si ce n'est pas déjà fait
moi je vous dis à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo
[Musique]